For developers, if you've already
built an Android app for your phone,
you're just a few enhancements away
from it working on your tv as well.
Let's start with the Creative Vision for
Android TV.
Which will help you understand
the difference between building on
something like a phone and
building for the TV.
Now, sum this up quickly.
You want to create an experience
that's Casual, Cinematic and Simple.
By Casual we mean that it should
be easy going, TV is not work.
Picture yourself hanging out with your
friends in the living room watching
a movie, playing a game, or
just listening to some music.
For example, you don't want to have to
pick up the remote every five minutes to
play the next video,
the TV should just handle this for you.
In the Cinematic App,
the interface should just fade away,
putting the content front and center.
Tell your story with pictures and
sound instead of text and menus.
And finally, everything should be so
simple that it feels magical.
Minimize steps, avoid text entry,
just get the user to their content.